die Retter von der Bergwacht Feldberg
sind im Dauereinsatz verunglückte
Skifahrer Stürze auf eisglatten Pisten
in dieser Wintersaison häufen sich die
Unfälle
das Retterteam ist unterwegs eine
Skifahrerin nach einem Sturz ist eine
andere Frau in sie hineingefahren dabei
ist der Arm verletzt worden der nun
notdürftig auf der Piste geschient wird
also es ist mein erster Tag heute und
generell
Anfängerkurs war das gerade oder leicht
fortgeschrittener Skikurs und ist schon
schwierig gewesen also jetzt mit dem Eis
man rutscht viel es ist super viel los
finde ich ähm ja das war jetzt nicht
ganz so einfach zum Starten viele
Wintersportler sind auf dem Pisten des
Feldbergs unterwegs auf dem höchsten
Berg Baden-Württembergs ist erst seit
kurzem das Skifahren wieder möglich
endlich hat es geschneit auch die
31-Jährige Besucherin aus der Pfalz
wollte das Ausnutzen mein erster Gedanke
war ich flieg im 6 Wochen nach Südafrika
und habe mein Freund gesagt verletzt
sich auf keinen Fall heute und jetzt
will ich die schon aber ich hoffe dass
wirklich eine Prellung ist aber es ist
Tat schon sehr sehr wenig ja sie schafft
es gerade noch aus eigener Kraft auf den
Skibob der sie nun zur Bergwacht bringt
dort wird ihr Arm für die anschließende
Fahrt ins Krankenhaus ruhig gestellt
eine schmerzhafte Angelegenheit für die
31-Jährige ihr Arm muss geröntgt werden
dafür kommt sie nun ins Krankenhaus
[Musik]
kurz danach sind die Männer von der
Bergrettung zu einem verletzten Jungen
unterwegs fast 30 Pistenkilometer rund
um den Feldberg decken die Bergretter in
ihren einsetzen ab der zehnjährige Elias
wartet schon auf Sie eine Skifahrerin so
erzählt er hat ihn den weg geschnitten
so dass er ausweichen musste und gegen
eine pistenbegrenzung gefahren ist mit
hoher Geschwindigkeit nun hat der starke
Schmerzen im Arm guck mal meine Hand
beide danke danke
[Musik]
auf die bergretungswache da haben wir
den Arzt dann können wir nicht im warmen
einmal durchchecken aber wir müssen
damit wahrscheinlich ziemlich sicher man
ins Krankenhaus fahren um zu gucken ob
dein Arm irgendwo gebrochen sein könnte
der kann auch zu uns an die
Bergrettungswache kommen
mit einer Verletzung am linken Arm
starke Schmerzen dann aber der Transport
wird gehen wir schauen uns auf der
Bergstraße genauer an es war Zustand
nach Kollision also wir müssen die
Polizei noch informieren den
Fahrerflucht gibt es auch auf der Piste
die Unfallverursacherin war einfach
weitergefahren erzählt Elias Bergwacht
Arzt Christian Jakob untersucht Elias
noch einmal intensiver der Mainzer Junge
war heute mit zwei Freunden in den
Schwarzwald angereist die auch
Unfallzeugen waren
die haben dann auch die Frau dann
angesprochen ja
die hat sich wohl aber eher geärgert ja
und hat den Jungs gesagt sieh zu dass er
weiterkommt und ich selbst weggefahren
und das war halt die Situation wo uns
dann geärgert haben
dass sie dann so ein Kind in hilfloser
Position dann einfach zurück lässt Elias
wird nun ins Krankenhaus gefahren hier
soll abgeklärt werden ob sein Arm durch
den Zusammenprall gebrochen ist das
Leute wirklich Kollision haben und das
dann auch mal Leute wegfahren weil sie
entweder nicht merken oder nicht merken
wollen das gibt's schon öfter ja das
haben wir schon öfter und dann ist hier
oben ganz klar geregelt die Polizei wird
mit dazu geholt wie bei einem
Verkehrsunfall auch und dann nimmt die
den Unfall auf und häufig sind die Leute
halt nicht mehr zu ermitteln an den
Wochenenden sind mindestens zehn Männer
und Frauen im Einsatz alle Arbeiten hier
ehrenamtlich haben eine dreijährige
Ausbildung hinter sich viele sind
zusätzlich rettungs- oder
Notfallsanitäter es ist ein sehr
einsatzreicher Tag für die Bergwacht am
Feldberg die Saison hat jetzt auch
relativ spät angefangen im Schwarzwald
aufgrund der geringen Schneelage und das
ist natürlich auch viele Menschen zum
ersten Mal heute auf dem Ski unterwegs
und dementsprechend hoch ist dann
natürlich auch das Verletzungsrisiko die
Liftanlagen können hier stündlich bis zu
35.000 Personen befördern so einfachen
familienpiste oder anspruchsvollen
Weltcupstrecke
heute jagt ein Einsatz den nächsten
schon wieder ein Notfall ein 18-Jähriger
Skilehrer ist gestürzt hat sich das Knie
verletzt liegt unterhalb der Piste der
junge Mann hat starke Schmerzen deshalb
liegt Arzt Christian Jakob gleich vor
Ort einen Zugang um ein Schmerzmittel zu
geben
aber wir versuchen das eigentlich immer
erst mal dass man das ohne Schmerzmittel
hinbekommt wenn das halt nicht geht wie
jetzt in dem Fall dass wir das mit dem
umlagern dass es von den Schmerzen so
schlimm ist für den Patienten dass es
nicht geht dann brauchen wir eine
Schmerzmittel Gabe kurz darauf wirkt das
Schmerzmittel und der Skilehrer ist nun
transportfähig als nächstes wartet ein
Krankenwagen auf ihn wahrscheinlich eine
Patellaluxation dass die Kniescheibe zur
Seite gesprungen ist recht schmerzhaft
gerade bei Bewegung keine Zeit zum
Durchatmen hat heute auch Bergretter
Jakob Schmied schon wieder ist ein
Einsatz reingekommen also wir haben eine
gestürzte Skifahrerin unten auf der
Skipiste unterhalb unserer Rettungswache
und wir fahren jetzt mal hin und schauen
was eigentlich los ist der Alarm kam
gerade über die Leitstelle genau gut
dann mach mal Feuer an die Piste ist an
einigen Stellen vereist viele Skifahrer
und Snowboarder stürzen unterschätzen
die Bedingungen es gibt immer noch zu
wenig Schnee deshalb kommen immer öfter
vereiste Stellen zum Vorschein die ist
gerade Anfänger nicht leicht machen dazu
kommt teilweise eine schlechte Sicht
mittlerweile ist Jakob Schmid am
Unfallort angekommen eine 26 Jahre alte
Frau hat sich bei einem Sturz das linke
Knie verdreht
alles klar Sonntag aber nirgends
Schmerzen nach dem Sturz auf dem Kopf
gefallen ist auch nicht okay
alles klar ich würde trotzdem einmal
kurz bisschen Abtasten wenn du
feststellen dass irgendwo weh tut sag
Bescheid okay wenn ich hier zur klopfe
keine Beschwerden oder
das Bein mit dem Knie kannst du das
Bewegen ganz dachte ja das geht auch
okay aber es tut weh oder dann lassen
wir das einfach so ähm also das sieht so
aus du musst auf jeden Fall eine im
Krankenhaus damit das geröntgt werden
kann professionell unaufgeregt sind die
Bergretter bei ihrer Arbeit die junge
Frau wird nun mit dem Skibob hinunter
zur Bergwacht Station gefahren
dort erlebt Arzt Christian Jakob täglich
was so ein Sturz anrichten kann also die
meisten sind schon so Knie oder arm eine
Klappe immer so aus dem ausgestreckten
Arm fällt oder die Snowboarder die sich
versuchen abzufangen oder so ein häufig
so Frakturen im Unterarmbereich und bei
Mashima hat halt ein relativ großen
Hebel dann dreht das Bein auch gerne mal
raus und dann Kniebänder Jakob Schmied
und seine Kollegen sind schon wieder
unterwegs ein Kind ist beim Skifahren
gestürzt
so hi ich bin Jakob von der Bergwacht
was ist passiert
kannst du dich daran erinnern was
passiert ist
noch immer sitzt der Schreck tief bei
der kleinen Skifahrerin mehr als die
Hälfte aller Unfälle passiert mit
Kindern also wir hatten jetzt eine
Patientin 9 Jahre weiblich sicher beim
Skifahren gestürzt und hat sich leicht
im Gesicht aufgeschürft ich denke das
war eher der Schock also so der
Schrecken beim Stürzen das ist am Anfang
ein bisschen schlecht ging wir nehmen
jetzt mal hoch mit ins Warme dann kann
sich ein bisschen beruhigen und ich
denke dann kann sie einfach wieder
weiter Skifahren heute für das Mädchen
und ihren Vater geht's nun erst einmal
von der vereisten Piste hinunter zur
Bergwacht zum Glück reicht diesmal ein
Pflaster aus und der Skitag kann für das
Mädchen weitergehen dann ist nicht ganz
empfindlich beim Skifahren
mehr als 1.500 mal rückte die Bergwacht
im Schwarzwald im vergangenen Jahr aus
in Briefen und Zeichnungen bedanken sich
die geretteten bei ihren Rettern
das ist tatsächlich so dass ich die
Leute dann doch sehr oft im Nachhinein
noch mal melden oder auch vorbeikommen
und sich bedanken dafür dass wir sie von
der Piste oder aus dem Gelände geholt
haben es freuen uns natürlich immer mega
weil das ist auch motiviert weiter zu
machen ehrenamtlich wird es sich im
Prinzip ja wir kriegen kein Geld dafür
dass wir das machen und dann ist so das
schon eine Belohnung eine Bezahlung
dafür man weiß dass man das Richtige
gemacht hat der nächste Einsatz diesmal
wurden sie zu einem Lift gerufen dort
blutet ein junger Mann aus dem Mund
männlich 23 Jahre ausgeschlagener Zahn
wir kommen zurück zur Wachen und dann
gucken wir wie es weitergeht für den
23-Jährigen und seine Freundin endet das
Skiwochenende am Feldberg zu dem sie
extra aus Belgien angereist waren das
war jetzt ein Patient der hat einen
liftbügel ins Gesicht bekommen sich
dabei einen Zahn ausgeschlagen
ja das ist auch so ein Klassiker das hat
man ab und zu mal ist halt blöd der Zahn
war in dem Fall jetzt weg
lass Lorenz und Arzt Christian Jakob
wurden zum Seeburg gerufen eigentlich
eine leichte Familie Abfahrt aber hier
hängt der Nebel fest Unebenheiten auf
der Piste sind kaum zu sehen einer
Jungfrau wurde das zum Verhängnis ihr
Skitag hat hier ein jedes Ende gefunden
sie hat starke Schmerzen im rechten Bein
bekommt noch auf der Piste intravenös
ein Schmerzmittel von Arzt Christian
Jakob das ist nötig damit die Frau
transportfähig wird
[Musik]
wenn man liegend die Patienten
transportieren in die eben in diesem
Anhänger quasi und dann fahren wir
runter an die buswendeplatte und dort
kommt dann der Rettungswagen und
transportiert sie in die Klinik
insgesamt 23 Mal rückten die Männer und
Frauen von der Bergwacht Feldberg an
diesem Wochenende aus für die kommenden
Tage wird Neuschnee erwartet neue
Einsätze sind also garantiert
[Musik]